NO NO NO NO NO NO NO
NO NO NO
NO
What the heck is going on people? Use Tide Pods for washing, NOT eating.
MEME REVIEW!
MEME REVIEW.
Do not listen to this man.
For he is just trying to hide the succulent flavor.
The ssswour sweetness and the euphoric sensation-
Of the Tide Pods. I am NOT saying eat the Tide Pods. I am saying...
*devil voice* ENGORGE YOURSELF IN THEM.
DISCLAMER: Do not actually consume tide pods or any such detergent, this is a joke, and felix is not to be held responsible if you chose to do so. (you're welcome brad.)
Welcome to MEME REVIEW. YouTube's  favorite show of all time.
This is an important series that we are reviewing all the memes.
Meme Review!
Numba 1!!
It could possibly be the greatest meme of all time.
This meme means more to me than any other meme we have previously discussed because-
It is my meme, my children. Yes, that's right. Take a seat.
But can you do this?
*Christian music*
No, you can't. Unless you bought my chair. 399 by the way. We here, we have Logan Paul.
Logan: Hey, PewDiePie, my merch is better.
PewDiePie: But can you do this?
"Can you do this" The greatest meme of all time.
Because that's right my sweet children, It is MY meme.
This meme started with me announcing my chair.
And I was just going through the basic features of them- of the chair.
can your chair do this? I don't think so, okay?
This thing is the goddamn Lamborghini of chairs, it's not a chair, it's a lifestyle.
as generous and wonderful I am, I had a nice tutorial of this chair.
buy my chair it's only 399 [laughing ]
Yes, yes it is only 399 and I'll have you- let you know, but can you do this!
I don't think so!
the meme continued
*wheeze*
in later episodes of LWIAY
(Totally original idea, btw)
and from there it just spread like wildfire
It just went left and right, can you do this?
Whenever you hear someone says...
Something and you go, "but", immediate reaction is
*extreme distortion* BUT CAN YOU DO THIS
More addicting then, dare I say the
dAmn DanIELLLLLL
Here we have men, women, deficient...
and Pewdiepie
and you can't do this
that's the joke because you can't do it. Only the exclusive club members that owned the
399 chair of God can enjoy this meme properly
somebody touched my spaget
someone in this house
[laugh]
So you can touch spaghetti with this meme. I'm the tallest tower in the world. but can u dew this
399 that's a great price! that's a great offer! That's a great price!
consider yourself lucky!
Hey look. We're on an airplane.
but can u do dis
[laughing]
Excuse me, sir. I'm gonna have to ask you to put your chair up
right now-
[demon awakens]
How's it going bros my names PewDiePie!
umm
Today we have these muscle relaxants, I'm gonna put them on me. Okay, so do we know our partmar...Partner
partner
Okay, first question favorite ways to relax
I don't know uhhh
Mariza: poods can you-
Pewdiepie: sew?
Mariza:Can you.
Pewdiepie:Cover the pugs?
Mariza: Every night I ask you
Pewdiepie: Give you a glass of water?
Mariza: Nooo
Mariza: Poods can you-
CAN YOU DO THIS
EH?
EHH
I DON'T THINK SO EHHHH
[Laugh]
That's right!
That's right. You can't, you can't do this. Only I can do this, get with the times [choking noises]
That was a Ugandan spit, that's right, the- ugandan meme really died out quick didn't it
*overlapping video segments of Pewdiepie talking about his chair.*
PewDiePies: but cAN YoU dO thIS
cAN yOU DO tHis
Humanity has peaked!! This is it. This is the high point that we've all been looking for when it comes to the memes
It's never going to be a better meme than this! My favorite one is still this one. It's so good
Obi Wan Kenobi: It's over Anakin, i have the high ground!
Anakin (PewDiePie's voice): BUT CAN yOU dO ThIS
[Laughing]
So gOOD! it's- oh man
Such a funny wonderful relatable meme. PewDiePie chair added to cart, $399
very nice [laughing]
Now of course people tried they they wonder, "hum, maybe I can do this". So they try and challenge me
Sending me stupid images of fake chairs. That's not my chair, and I bet you that chair
Is not 399 as impressive as it may be yes, yes, they say yes the chair can do this
But no, no it cannot
I am sorry sue-me-ma-Sen. Get the **** out!
Hello, My name is Yuri. I have timid expression, mature sex figure and big boobies
I can write puns with deep meaning using complex words, and I will die because I love you
But can you do this, [laugh]
We have incredible fan art from this meme
uhh- look at this pixel art
Beautiful! We have animations! and even more incredible animations
I love this one btw. We even have songs about can you do this?
bUt can you do thIS
but can you do thIS
butt cAN YOU DO THIISS
BuT can yOU DO THIS
but can you do this?!?!
buut can you do thIS
BUT CAN YOU DO THIS
butt kan u do dis
[beat banging]
The origin of this meme is
100% mine, and it does not come at all, at all!
From this old meme from like what 2012 where they say: "yo you your smartphone think you're so great
Huh? but can you do this?"
Or maybe then th- the twoDS "you think you're so great huh, but can you do this?"
"Ah you SNES classic minis think you're so great, Huh? but can you do this?"
It even got so far that the creator of this webcomic had to tweet out
"Tfw you started making some comics with the catchphrase 'But can you do this?' in 2013
But then PEWDIEPIE uses it and everybody thinks you're refer- referencing his chair meme
That's great and all...
BUT CAN YoU DO THIS
I DON THINK SO
*intense rock music with intense voice* This meme is mine, it is mine, and I've copyrighted it and I will send
6,000 lawyers your way, lolnein.
If you want a war, then a war you shall have.
'Cause you do not --- you may--- you may talk trash about my dog,
You may talk trash about my channel, you may talk trash about my girlfriend
But you talk trash about my Meme, and you will FACE
the wrath of-
*back to normal*  gAH! gAaH! I will kill you!!
I will destory you!..
HAHH
Now this meme, to be honest, it's...
It's a PewDiePie meme. It's not gonna get a high rating. It's immediately two points...
Let's say it's a 10 out of 10 meme, all right, let's remove two points right off the bat
'cause it's PewDiePie related.
Let's remove two points right off the bat because it's a Normie meme at this point.
Remove another two point five points
Because it has absolutely no racism, sexism
Suicidal undertones, none of that!
No problematic undertones, it's actually family-friendly meme so remove another point and uhh
Which leads us to the overall score of
10 OUTTA 10!!!!
This is a 10 out of 10, the first 10 outta 10 meme that we have ever had
on meme review.
and probably ever will, btw.
Uh, I'm really proud to finally have the first 10 out of 10 meme on meme review, clap it up everyone!
We've done it, together. We did it. 10 out of 10 meme. Well done you and well done me.
Here we are. Now, of course, this meme has to die. *bong* This meme is dead, okay
Oh, don't be sad though all memes have to die, so don't be too--
Don't be too sad, but I don't want to see this meme ever again alright
It's gonna be, it's gonna be pretty bad, Okay? I'm gonna get really angrey. Don't post this meme anymore
It's not funny, it had a good life span
We- we should not taint this meme by overusing it when it's not longer funny
It was a good run everybody, it was a good run. Give yourself a pat on the back.
NEXT.
MEME.
"Skedaddle skedaddle,
Skedaddle skedoodle your.. ding dong is now a noodle."
This meme.. is a garbage meme.
Anytime I do a you laugh, you lose,
someone is posting this god-awful meme, and it just annoys the hell out of me..
and this is it:
"SKIDADDLE, SKIDOODLE,
YOUR DICK IS NOW A NOODLE."
*video plays shitty quasi-earrape*
This is the worst meme I have ever encountered in my entire life.
"Hey look, it's a--it's a you lafh you lose thread,
Oh, that's- that's- that's great- That's great. That's- see what- Oh look! It's this one
It's so funny. Every time I watch it, it gets better.
--NOODLE!
*shitty "earrape" music plays again*
Stop it.
I'm saying stop it now before anyone gets hurt.
*"look at this photograph" soundtrack by nickleback plays*
"sKiDaDDlE SKdOodDLe,
uR DiCC iS nOw A NOodLe!1!!"
Pewdiepie: IT IS NOT.
DON-
It is not!
Stop it!
Stop it! stop-
This is the worst meme I have ever encountered in my life. I'm rating this, that's right, a zero
Garbage meme. I don't- [another Ugandan spit] I spit on it
BOONUSSS MEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEME
This week's bonus meme everybody, clap it up. We have time for it. Lucky you.
"Pop team epic" or "Pup-- pup tap epic".
It's a manga, that has now come out as an anime.
It's not really memes from the manga, It's more the sense that the manga is the meme itself...
*choppy static*
*Groan of brewing anger*
[Spit]
Pewds reading: "Isn't the red color wonderful?" "So you can hide the color of blood with this."
"The hybrid car is very quiet"
"Right, so you can kill without making a soun-" *chuckles*
Check out pop team epic. It's basically an anime turned into one big shit post, it's beautiful,
I couldn't recommend it enough. It's not #SPON or anything,
It's more like, uh, if you're probably gonna see this appearing here and there and
now thanks to me, your fellow meme..review...
person, you can be like aha! I know where that's-that's from.
this meme, uh, It's not really memes, so I'm just gonna give it a seal of approval
Everybody.
That was this weeks meme review everybody! clap it up, which one was your favorite meme?
Let me know in the comments down below,
What do you want me to review next?
and remember, to keep on smiling everybody.
*pewds awkwardly staring at the camera as he fakes positivity*